vous avez l'impression que cette pipe
est énorme n'est ce pas et bien non tout
n'est question que de perspectives
vous souvenez-vous de ce fameux jeu
auquel on avait joué qui jouait sur les
perspectives se fait beaucoup de jouer
dans une seule phrase et je parle pas de
celui là moi je mettrais bien d'inscrits
sont ceux qui n'ont pas vu mais tu
pouvais de d'en prendre un objet et le
faire devenir énorme l'éloignant voilà
par exemple pour la tour eiffel à faire
devenir un porte-clés tour eiffel eh ben
j'ai trouvé un deuxième jeu du même
genre calais a c'est un peu différent
mais vous allez voir c'est tout aussi
cool c'est un jeu où le fond et noir les
objets sont tous en blanc mais ils n'ont
pas de contours ni dhombres ce qui fait
que tu as beaucoup de mal à différencier
les objets et que le seul moyen de les
différencier c'est de tourner autour
pour qu'un perspective change
vous avez compris fait majeur mais
franchement je me suis craqué pour que
mes explications soit compréhensible
c'est parti à 16 niveaux et mais qu'on
va se craquelle cerveau une fois de plus
mais c'est trop cool à ce parti donc on
a pas dans cette forme et en avançant et
en tournant on va se rendre compte que
voilà qu'en fait il y avait deux formes
tout simplement je fais je trouve ça
génial aussi du coup on va devoir monter
là dessus et le but de chaque level
c'est d'aller prendre la petite boule
jaune qui se situe ici voilà alors le
mail suivant up bourassa a non [ __ ] du
coup le du coup le pouls et blanc sur
blanc
alors comment pouvoir saffré java me
baisser non regardez je vois grâce au
noir la merde qu'est donc fait cette
forme [ __ ] sémalens espère voilà du
coup à mon avis la whey [ __ ] c'est à
merde tu as et dieu y a une technique
particulière pensée pour bien apercevoir
le truc con et youba je crois pas là et
là maintenant c'est un peu de droit
genre ouais ouais non non non
quoi il ya un trou non mes mecs mais
c'est super dur de ouf c'est hyper chaud
grâce à ce très noir je vois à peu près
où le trou voyez même pas un mec je suis
allé au culot
voilà à l'eau c'est très malin en vrai
comme jeu [ __ ] on a fait 3 le valmont
gage ne sont plus mais là on ne comprend
rien aux croyants salaire je saute au
cas où je pense qu'il faut sauter à mort
faut plus haute et que mario est là du
coup comment je fais pour voir ce cas
quand je lui dois une passerelle un truc
cacher c'est sûr n'en faut que je saute
comme ça tout droit oui non ok no 40
compliqué en fait juste une montée
derrière il ya un gros saut à faire mais
c'est dur de voir où atterrir parce que
il ya du blanc quel principe même du jeu
donc à bien tous ok j'ai compris la
forme en fait faut monter là en vrai ça
va à gauche ici hop
et voilà c'est faux ne m'écoutez jamais
à temps on va tourner autour là puisque
c'est ce qu'on a c'est ce qu'on n'a pas
assez fait je trouve à ok j'ai compris
ça en fait c'est juste une paroisse
c'est pas un support ça c'est juste une
paroi et moi j'arrive donc c'était un
pont si votre cerveau explose c'est
normal vous en faites pas là en fait
j'ai besoin qui est un pont est en fait
c'est faux il
roy la verticale est un truc plein il
faut que je saute de l'autre côté comme
j'ai fait tout à l'heure et là
normalement on est dessus où tu as été
compliqué mon gars celui-là c'est quoi
le piège là je ne comprends pas le piège
au les [ __ ]
je fais comment là haut je croyais que
c'était des dalles noire et blanche mais
non y'a que des dalles noir et les
dalles transparentes mais vu qu en
dessous c'est du bluff a besoin que ses
hommes [ __ ] c'est oui parce que notre
cerveau associe le blanc du coup un truc
sur lequel on peut marcher et le noir à
du vide et vu qu'un coup sûr de l'aube
il ya vraiment eu un enfant bref c'est
juste la profondeur de champ c'est
terrible oui donc là il faut que je
marche que sur les noirs sa technique
non en vrai on va faire une diagonale il
y aura pas une dalle noir ou d'un coup
elle se sent comme ça mais non à les
battages et compris le trx du niveau
c'est hyper malin en gros à droite les
dalles sur lesquels je peux marcher
c'est les noirs
le reste des dalles transparentes sur un
fond bleu en bas donc gerbe sont que
voilà et à gauche celle inverse c'est
les dalles blanches sur lesquelles je
peux marcher il aida noires qui sont en
fait transparente voilà c'est le sur le
quesnoy et c'est trop malin mais c'est
trop fort j'adore les gens qui aiment le
sudoku d'autres les mots croisés
d'autres les jeux qui tue ton cerveau le
problème c'est que hacker moment je peux
voir là à regarder là on voit la up
et voilà maintenant pas sur le blanc et
le noir c'est le sol que ya en bas j'ai
expliqué au kawa ça se trouve vous ai
besoin d'explications de bolos mais on
est dessus
yes phospho vraiment tourner autour pour
voir par exemple la voyez on dirait
qu'elle est juste un truc blanc qu'en
fait c'est faux il ya un truc noir
devant un truc blanc auriez une parole
et passerelles ça va être dur de les
voir tu vois la passerelle blanche que
quand elle est sur fond noir tu vois la
passerelle noir qui collait sur fond
blanc [ __ ] j'aime trop je trouvais le
jeu qui tue le plus son cerveau de tous
les jeux qu'on a pu faire
donc là elle est là à peu près je la
vois ok je boucle amer faut que je me
déplace en même temps en plus c'est pas
je suis tuellement ben c'est que je dois
avancer en même temps à la la la la la
donc le mieux à mon avis en fait c'est
de prendre un noir javier jeu vidéo
j'avais su ça le fait yes alors ici on a
walk et c'est que ce bordel hockey à
oued profil sur fond blanc là on est
bien là on s'en rend compte et encore
chaud qui a des trucs blanc qu'on voit
pas comme ça on se rendrait compte
non c'est bon il ya vraiment que du noir
ouais sauf cas que du noir mais je dois
refaire tous à deux faces regardez-moi
ça hop et là je ne vois plus rien je
peux plus évaluer les distances c'est
fini pour moi donc je crois que attend
de tête de côté ce qu'on peut la voir
apparaître non j'en avais une la ouais
on la voit à peu près grâce au fond
blanc j'étais un mec mais c'est
tellement bien joué bravo à les lapider
de nous du courage faut que je nettoie
parce que à mon avis un genre 18
maladies dessus l'a vu tout les faux
j'ai fait tomber par terre
je fasse quoi là ça c'est un mur ça
c'est un mur la lie à un trou paumé mais
qu à droite c'est un meilleur là c'est
un mur donc faut contourner comme ça oh
[ __ ] ok d'accord ok jeté dans un cube
hockey [ __ ] les mecs c'est ce que ce
je me mets dans la gueule à chaque
seconde à ce que je peux sauter la ja a
du coup je vois pas le trou parce que le
trou c'est que du noir mais il est là je
le sais je les ai vus et merde il est un
peu plus sur la gauche vraiment en face
quand je suis là fonctionnent tout droit
donc logiquement on va là et là non
c'est tout droit en fait voilà voilà
voilà voilà vous êtes rendu compte vous
êtes content moi oui nouveau niveau
où sommes-nous que du blanc et un seul
joueur noir on va tourner autour le truc
jaune et là il est du coup sûr une mini
plateforme kader cette plateforme là
c'est comme tout à l'heure ça va être
dur de seront mais comment je suis
comment je fais pour monter il ya rien
pour monter une paroi noir un bloc un
bloc
un autre bloc qui est là et ça en fait
c'est une sorte de cube escaliers c'est
ça comment je fais pour me rendre compte
là bas il faut que j'aille au culot il
ya un truc que je dois mal faire ou
shula de fuck à temps non mais là c'est
chaud attend non ok d'accord c'est ça
c'est une sorte d escalier d'accord ok
c'est un escalier et voilà on recommence
rebelote c'est un escalier en fait à
droite il ya la marche à gauche et là
hop là on est au plus haut on sait qu'il
ya une paroisse tout droit et calculs
jaune qui est juste là ok c'est bon
est-ce que vous avez compris quelque
chose oui général par contre la séquence
vraiment à faire mal au crâne jo cette
vidéo des deux devrait être sponsorisé
par l'aspirine austin où il est prêté
par contre on voit tout un an quoi que
l'on voit pas on voit pas la dr
plateforme et voilà et bien non pas toi
où l'attend qu'est ce qui se passe là on
a juste un truc noir avec un truc ça
c'est du vide tu paraît que ça c'est du
vide on parie combien on prend le pari
je fais gagner c'est emballages vides
si ce n'est pas du vide et vous allez
vous devez tous un emballage vie de mon
gars je vais toquer chez intermarché je
vais la revendre ou kg à devenir riche
par contre quand j'ai pour monter j'ai
gagné un pari je suis auteur mais quand
je devais avoir démarche que je vois pas
un mec ça un boîte faut sauter un quoi
au québec les prix
ok alors là et du rouge man en
maintenance et du rouge et du noir mais
ça change pas le problème
mes mecs le parcours ok donc là pour est
là on commence à rentrer dans les levées
avec une difficulté si tu veux qu est un
peu un peu saignante quoi comme ton
steak le midi alors en gros le truc
journée là bas là on voit qu'il ya une
petite passerelle qui va nous amener sur
cette grosse passerelle de cette grosse
passerelle on va devoir se passera l
espace autres l on va devoir sauter sur
cette plus grande passerelle tu va nous
amener là dessus là dessus on longe ça
nous amène là et d'ici à mon avis il
faut sauter la voilà dix il falloir
sauter là bas mais vu que c'est sur fond
rouge je me rendrai compte je pourrais
voir le vide aux halles et incomprise
par hab ok ben amos ok on saute
ok on a rejoint la plateforme la plus
grande on saute on prend un raccourci
voilà si vous aimez que c'est sur fond
rouge je peux évaluer les distances ce
qui m'arrange énorme m là je crois qu'il
ya un pont wallah il suffit de sauter
pour voir apparaître
et là par contre ok un petit carré
jusque là et là là par contre c'est le
fond noir donc là je fais et je propose
de sauter là dessus qu'est ce vous avez
tout ça devient dur c'est ça que j'adore
si la difficulté elle fait vraiment
c'était une cour là ce que j'ai fait
quand même
oh on pourrait croire la pochette du
prochain album de justin
vrai ou faux alors mais tu sais quoi je
suis sûr que c'est beaucoup plus profond
voilà et qu'il n'y paraît jamais été sur
1,6 alors [ __ ] de mecs cet homme là ça
va être chaud de différencier les
reliefs up donc là il ya un truc
ok c'est bon tu avais la mecque je peux
indifférence ici on me répond par
rapport au sol ça s'est passé je regarde
par terre
est ce qu'un moyen de faire le coup du
vivat mètres du sol noir en dessous et
du coup je vais croire que je suis
content une marche et là où il faut
alors que non non c'est bon alors hop tu
as un mec c'est une arène le truc quand
on a une plate forme ici qui va mener
vers l'une de ces deux plateformes à
faut que je sois content ah voilà là on
voit bien là on aime bonnes perspectives
on a une bonne vue d'ensemble tout ce
que je vous dis alors à temps est-ce que
déjà ça le fait ouais ça le fait ouais
ça le fait
et là alors je fais quoi ah c'est une
plateforme rouge excellent on dirait
juste que le seuil de le seul noir est
divisé en deux mais non plateforme rouge
ça le fait est là je peux y aller ou
weimar du vide c'est sûr c'est pas
possible soit aussi simple
si c'est bon ils n'ont pas fait leur
preuve jusqu'au bout aux mondiaux des
gens gentils sur cette planète
ah c'est bon c'est la fin et je suis sûr
c'est une feuille porte si c'est pas une
feuille port que je fais gagner ça les
pompes haricots verts c'est hyper
profond non c'est vraiment une porte
mais non oh mon dieu j'ai rien compris
gérard oury mais c'est grave culpa du
coup je vous rends à tous vos déchets en
plastique voilà finalement je vais pas
toquer chez intermarché
je vous laisse deviner riches à ma place
ah ça fait du [ __ ] mais j'ai besoin de
revivre de différencier les objets de
voir un premier plan en 2d plein
troisième plan rigole photographie on
sait bien on connaît bien on connaît
bien les connards plastiques au collège
qui nous ont appris ça alors c'est bon
je l' ai vu je les faisais monde pas
obligé de me grey 11 en effet c'est bon
c'est bon le soleil et c'est la fin
[ __ ] génial et je me suis resté très
proche du bilan quelle belle conclusion
de merde pour un si beau jeu et voilages
enveloppes artiste vidéo sur contraste
n'hésitez pas à aller mais si elle vous
a plu j'ai adoré cieux j'adore les jeux
comme ça ça a été fait en 24 heures et
je soutiendrai mutants développer de
trois épreuves un peu différente par
exemple le truc des dalles là où d'un
coup les dalles s'inverse je suis bouche
bée nessman dans les commentaires si
vous avez bien les petits jeux comme ça
un peu qui joue sur les perspectives ou
qui font bien réfléchir un kit eux qui
te cramer raoult finalement atterrir
d'embauché portez vous bien de
chazournes petit concours pour gagner
[Musique]